[Music]
hello bachelor nation i'm lauren zima
and monday night ABC made a historic
announcement ladies and gentlemen please
welcome our next Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsay Rae
yes our new bachelorette is Rachel
Lindsay making her the first black
bachelor or bachelorette in franchise
history this is a bit of a spoiler cuz
you're still on the show yes it is but
you know we're a couple of weeks out for
filming we're ready to get this started
I'm ready to find love find a husband so
if you know anybody out there who needs
to apply et was exclusively on set for
Rachel's one-on-one with Nick vile in
October we asked her about diversity
among the contestants then diversity is
an issue has come up on The Bachelor
before how you feel about it it's very
noticeable the diversity that's there
and it it just shows how open Nick is to
dating women regardless of like their
cultural background or their ethnicity
or what they do or their age and that's
really exciting I told Nick all the time
every time I talk to him I'm like how
are you doing because I cannot imagine
what it's like to be able to
compartmentalize every relationship with
the women in these house so what I'm
impressed by is his ability to be able
to do that well what do you think of
Rachel as the choice for the new
bachelorette let me know over on Twitter
you